wir starten in oppenau hier ist eine
großfahndung die polizei suchte einen
bewaffneten mann mit tarnkleidung am
vormittag wurde dieser verdächtige
gemeldet er hat sich wohl in einer hütte
im bereich oppenau aufgehalten der
methan muss dann bekleidete mann soll
unter anderem pfeile und einen bogen bei
sich haben eine anschließende kontrolle
des verdächtigen brachte außerdem ans
licht dass er auch ein messer und eine
pistole bei sich trugen jetzt kommt er
soll die beamten massiv bedroht und
sogar entwaffnet haben ja danach
flüchtete er in den wald also derzeit
fahndet ein großaufgebot nach diesem
mann die polizei warnt auch wirklich
alle personen rund um oppenau vor diesen
verdächtigen und bittet sich schnellst
möglich sind auch nur zu hause
aufzuhalten es kann bislang nicht genau
beurteilt werden ob sich der bewaffnete
möglicherweise in einer psychischen
ausnahmesituation befindet und welche
gefahr vor allem von ihm ausgeht
der pressesprecher der polizei sagt in
offenburg übrigens das zu bild wir
hatten heute morgen als wir hatten heute
morgen einen anruf einen hinweis dass
ich ein verdächtiger mann bewaffnet mit
pfeil und bogen in einer hütte aufhalten
soll
das haben wir überprüft mit zwei
streifen sind wir angefahren der mann
ist unseren kollegen unseren streifen
mit einem messer und mit einer pistole
davon hatten wir bis dahin keine
kenntnis entgegen getreten und hatte da
so die kollegen bedroht und letztendlich
ist es ihm sogar gelungen diese
polizisten zu entwaffnen
die einsatzkräfte gehen hier vor wir
haben im moment über 100 einsatzkräfte
hier im einsatz verteilt auf mehrere
polizeipräsidien spezialeinsatzkommandos
und einsatzkommando hundestaffel und
auch kräfte der kriminalpolizei aalen
verkehrspolizei also wir hören dass so
ziemlich alles was man aufwand kann ich
spreche jetzt mit meiner kollegin lisa
seitz militärpolizisten entwaffnen das
hört sich eher an wie wie geht das ja
die polizisten sind sich selbst noch
nicht sicher wie genau das funktioniert
hat die vier polizisten die an am ort
war
haben sich wohl in einer defensiven
haltung gefunden also haben nicht damit
gerechnet dass sie bedroht werden
der angreifer ist dann mal auf sie zu
auch mit einer pistole und hat sie
überwältigt wie genau ist noch unklar
die vier waffen der vier polizisten
fehlen auch also der täter hat sie wohl
mit sich mitgenommen
wahnsinn das hat sich wirklich verrückt
an kannst du uns was sagen über den
täter weiß so mehr als jetzt schon
gesagt also viel ist noch nicht bekannt
der s31 hat keinen wohnsitz
er komponierte ging ist hier bekannt so
ist man immer auch auf die schliche
gekommen durch die ganzen merkmale die
die polizisten nennen konnten wie zum
beispiel seine größe ist 1 70 groß
schlank hat einen kinnbart eine glatze
dadurch ist man ihm auf die schliche
gekommen kollegen war der mann bekannt
sie haben dann die datenbank durchsucht
dort ist man auch darauf gestoßen dass
er polizeilich bekannt ist und zwar
wegen verstößen gegen das waffengesetz
verstehe und weißt du welche gefahr von
ihm ausgeht ich mein die polizei bittet
ja wirklich darum dass alle menschen zu
hause bleiben jetzt genau der ganze ort
ist abgeriegelt auch die bundesstraße
hier ist abgeriegelt
man geht davon aus dass er in einem
psychischen ausnahmezustand ist und die
tatsache dass er die polizisten
überwältigt hat zeigt ja auch es ist ein
krimineller der polizeisprecher zu mir
gesagt die ganzen bewohnern hier im ort
sollen am besten noch daheim bleiben
weil einfach jede spur von ihm fehlt ja
noch nicht aufgetaucht ist alles klar
lisa seitz vielen dank an diesem punkt
von dir und ich wünsche dir trotzdem
noch einen schönen sonntagabend danke
dir